ladies and gentlemen a funeral ease
being the determining officer for the
parliamentary election for the
Kilmarnock and Louden constituency
hereby declare that the total number of
votes cast for each candidate in the
said election was as follows Alan brown
Scottish National Party SNP 19,000 690
lurid / Scottish Labour Party thirteen
thousand four hundred and twenty one
Alison Harper
Scottish conservative and unionist 12440
81 Scottish Liberal Democrats 994 and
that the said Alan brown has been duly
elected to serve as the Member of
Parliament for the Kilmarnock and
Loudoun constituency
I can see a few confused faces because
clearly my the number of audits formers
went down for the most important thing
as of one again I said before it was
such an honor to be elected to serve the
construction see I've spent my entire
life on ice and even bugger honor
demands to get reelected and that's the
most important thing I'm so proud to
have achieved up a late 2012 an officer
and all the staff involved for what
conduct an election and get again
Candice lieutenant very quickly again
like to thank the police for keeping us
safe events recently and Patel events at
Westminster are highlighted just what
the police do to try and protect the
public and I don't think we should
forget that nobody should ever go to a
job and there is a life not return home
to family will see not harm to too many
fees sorry I'm really grateful for the
job they do in protecting away the
public
I'd like to thank my agent is also my
wife Sunday thanks very much Sunday Rob
via senders access has you started on
your job which when say talk about my
campaigns has been a very difficult few
weeks but we've got their latest on my
campaign manager Jim Barton and all the
activists I've got a harvest for unto us
without years I could not be here and
it's much appreciated today the weather
was terrible and wheat activist out
sharpened doors Milan polling stations
absolute no doubt with the most activist
on the streets
and that's indicative of the support of
God and is reflected again is over the
finishing line here today though I'm so
proud to be elected that's no doubts
about about a sweet moment the fossil
eggs are the first result announced
saw a one more fantastic colleagues
Margaret Farrell is FC it looks like
there will be more of my great
colleagues the words of seats so I wish
all the best all the guys opens men then
got over the finest forensic on at the
can there is no doubt this NP pervaded
the real open session for the Tories for
the last couple of years
what sighs my heart's noggin reflected
and another construction sees tonight
but these guys were fantastic - what
wealth and hopefully as many as possible
organ erected
I represent the Scottish National Party
there's no doubt that Scottish National
Party as the father stone stands out for
Scotland where the euler party tonight
it was Phaeton every seat in scotland so
we will why we made suffer losses we've
thought that trying hard to fight every
seat no paper candidates we empty one
every seat and will continue to stand up
for Scotland I said my husband's I
believe the Tory Party aim to stoke the
version the ki vamonos altitude and that
was upon a rest man stuff I think it
looks good Theresa May is going to get
our comeuppance in that that's one thing
as well deserve politics has been very
untraced in the last few years remains
unclear remains volatile but one good
thing is that means voters of all a lot
if I wat I said that before force can
enact change in Marsala not so that's a
good thing for democracy say that
unpleasant I look forward about the
investments on these unpleasant times
standing up flick instruction say stand
up for Scotland and the promise I will
walk hard and I found all the voters
have put their faith in me once again
and thanks tough to hear
thank you